la grève n'aura finalement durée que
deux jours
assez pour que les employés de soutien
se fassent entendre et surtout assis
pour faire monter la pression sur le
gouvernement Ford alors que les
syndicats faisaient planer la menace
d'une grève générale
nous allons retirer la loi spéciale à
condition qu'ils mettent fin à la grève
à déclarer le Premier ministre d'octford
oui one
plus tard c'était au tour du syndicat de
célébrer sa victoire
55000 travailleurs de soutien seront
donc de retour dans les écoles dès
demain matin
[Applaudissements]
devant la législature ontarienne la
nouvelle est accueillie avec soulagement
par les grévistes
[Musique]
nous allons rentrer à la table de
négociations avec le gouvernement bien
sûr
car je vais pouvoir revoir mes amis
souris cet élève
mais le bras de fer est loin d'être
terminé et la question salariale
continue de diviser les deux parties
je dois agir de manière responsable avec
l'argent des contribuables à marteler
dogfords de négocier de bonne foi mais
n'hésiteront pas à débrayer à nouveau en
cas d'impasse
en reculant sur sa loi spéciale le
gouvernement Ford renonce aussi à
invoquer la disposition de dérogation de
la Charte canadienne des droits et
libertés le Premier ministre ontarien a
toutefois refusé de promettre qu'il
n'utiliserait pas cet outil exceptionnel
dans de futurs conflits travaillent lui
qui s'était pourtant fait élire on se
décrivant comme l'ami des syndicats
au Canada Toronto